[Music]
[Applause]
This is I'd Like to Know and we're
coming to you from the 62nd session of
the General Conference of Seventh Day
Adventists here in St. Louis, Missouri.
And we welcome you to our show. My name
is CA Murray. I'm in the company of two
fellow travelers on the road to glory.
To my right, Pastor Daniel Miranda.
Pastor, always good to have you here.
>> Thank you. It's good to be with you and
Pastor Salazar again.
>> And to my left, Pastor David Salazar,
who directs our Latino work here at Sum
TV. This, as we mentioned, is our
question and answer program. You send in
the questions. By the grace of God, we
give you the answers. That's kind of how
it works. If you want to get in on the
fun, may I encourage you to write us at
tvsums
as in marytv.org.
I'll say it once again, tvsumtv.org
and we will get to your question just as
soon as we can. If you don't hear it in
the first week after you send it in,
stick with us, stay by, we'll get to it
and we promise you that. Gentlemen, uh,
pastor, would you pray for us, please?
Yes. And then we'll launch out.
>> I would love to do that. Let us pray.
Heavenly Father which are in heaven. We
thank you so much for this general
conference session, the opportunity of
being here and um especially recording
this program from this place. We pray
that as we prepare our minds to give an
answer to your people that you may give
us clarity, you may give us wisdom and
help us also um practice these things
that you'll be revealing to us through
your word that the answer to these
questions may not be mere curiosity but
that we may sincerely seek to know your
will. We pray all these things in Jesus
name. Amen.
>> Amen. Pastor, thank you for the prayer.
Um, our first question comes from
Anonymous. I was teasing uh Pastor
Miranda that I I know Anonymous. I've
met anonymous before, but uh we don't
have any name, but we thank you for the
question. Uh just the same.
>> They want to know how can I know I've
truly surrendered to God if I keep
struggling with the same sin? Yeah,
>> I believe in justification by faith and
that Jesus forgives, but I often doubt
my sincerity when I fall into sin. I
don't want yet somehow still desire how
can I evaluate my walk with Jesus and
find assurance.
>> You know, I really I really resonate
with this question and I appreciate
whoever sent this question. I I see that
this question is coming from a very
sincere person that wants to please God.
And I think at some point in our lives,
we have all found ourselves in a similar
situation like this. We get discouraged.
We're trying to do our best to please
God, but we just keep falling or
sometimes it seems that
our Christian walk with Christ is not
victorious. But I want to assure you
that there is hope. You should not get
discouraged.
The problem that I see here is that your
eyes are too much on you. You need to
put your eyes on Jesus. If you look at
yourself, you're going to find enough
reasons to get discouraged. There is no
goodness in ourselves. There is no
holiness within ourselves. There is no
perfection in ourselves. Only in Jesus.
Yes, sometimes there are days that we
may not be as strong in other days, but
that doesn't mean that you are not a
Christian. That doesn't mean that you
are not loved by God. Christianity
character is evaluated by the trend of
your thoughts. Now if your trend of your
habits and thoughts are only towards
evil then you have a reason to be really
concerned because that will show that
there is another power that is reigning
in your life. But if you want to do the
will of God and in your best efforts to
please God sometimes you make mistakes
you should not get discouraged. I want
to share with you a quote that um is
very encouraging that is found in the
book Steps to Christ uh page 47. Steps
to Christ, page 47. I think this really
describes what you are saying here. It
says, "Many are inquiring,
how am I to make the surrender of myself
to God? You desire to give yourself to
him,
>> but you're weak in moral power,
enslavery to doubt and controlled by the
habits of your life of sin. Your
promises and resolutions are like ropes
of sand. You cannot control your
thoughts, your impulses, your
affections. The knowledge of your broken
promises and forfeited pledges weakens
your confidence in your own sincerity
and causes you to feel that God cannot
accept you. But you need not despair.
What you need to understand is the true
force of the will. This is the governing
power in the nature of man. The power of
decision or of choice. Everything
depends on the right action of the will.
The power of choice God has given to
men. It is theirs to exercise. You
cannot change your heart. You cannot of
yourselves give give to God the
affections.
But you can choose to serve him. You can
give your will and he will then work in
you to will and to do according to his
good pleasure. Thus your whole nature
will be brought under the control of the
spirit of Christ. Your affections will
be centered upon him. Your thoughts will
be in harmony with him. So here is the
answer to your question. The true
exercise of the will. It is not
dependent on feelings. Just choose what
is right. Even if you don't feel like
it, do not depend on your feelings to
tell you whether you're a Christian or
not. Exercise your will. The feelings
will come later. And this doesn't mean
that you will never heir again. This
surrender of the will has to be a daily
matter. As you daily surrender your will
to Christ, you will grow more and more
like him. I think pastor what you have
said is truly the the answer to the
question and I appreciate that you know
this individual is is searching to have
that victory to able to overcome he's
struggling with these things um as you
said something very important it is to
daily emphasize the need to come to the
lord now in the psalm 51
uh verses 6-9
and through 10 rather we have the
experience
of the daily walk that we should have
with the Lord. This is again a daily
experience that we need to have with
Christ. It says there in Psalms 51
6-10,
behold you desire truth in the inward
parts and in the hidden part you will
make me to know wisdom. Purge me with
hissup and I shall be clean. Wash me and
I shall be whiter than snow. Make my
heart my make me hear joy and gladness
that my bones you have broken may
rejoice. Hide your face from my sins and
blot out all my iniquities and create in
me a clean heart oh God and renew a
steadfast spirit within me. So the
experience that here David is saying he
recognizes the need for a inward change
a transformation of the heart not just
exterior but truly of the will of the
mind. But this cannot happen unless you
as it will said put your mind and your
will to accept that in your life
surrender
>> and that may mean that interesting here
that says purge me with hissup there's
an experience of cleansing that might
not be as smooth as you might want it to
be and the lord might send you trial
might actually ask you to refrain or to
remove from your life certain things
that trigger yes these inclinations or
that uh may feed into these desires that
you're having that you're struggling
with. A lot of devices, for example, a
lot of people that have advice that are
are prison to a vice is because usually
there is something that's triggering
within their reach. And it's important
that we are willing to say, Lord, if I
need to be removed from this experience
and you need to have a a place of of
cleansing, I need to make that decision
that that sacrifice, let me do so. So I
think that you are to come to the Lord
asking him change my heart, cleanse me,
but also do whatever it takes and I be
have to be willing to give up that which
may be hindering my communion with God,
my daily walk with Christ.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Um I want to synthesize uh what
you both said um particularly what you
said, Pastor Miranda, visa v feelings.
>> You can't go by your feelings and you
know that
The truth is uh we're all married. We
have we all have great wives. Um in
every marriage there come times when a
relationship is not as close as other
times. That's just humanity.
>> Sure.
>> So some days you feel very married. You
know you get up and you touch your wife.
Hi wife. Hi husband. You know you're
just very married. Then you have other
days when you're you don't feel quite so
married. You know maybe you went to bed
angry last night or something happened.
The truth is, gentlemen, that on the
days when you feel very married, you're
married. And on those days when you
don't feel quite so married, well, guess
what? You're still married.
>> You're still married. You're still
married. So, some days you feel like you
can carry the weight of the world.
>> Yes.
>> Other days you feel like you are
carrying the weight of the world.
>> So, you can't go by your feelings. You
cannot. You have to go by the word of
God. Amen.
>> Um, quickly, I want to go to Romans
because, uh, Paul in his letter, Romans
talks about the same thing. Yeah.
>> And and you know where I'm going. It's
Romans chapter 7. I'll try to get
through this as quickly as I can. I'll
start at verse 18. For I know that in me
that is in my flesh. Nothing good
dwells. For to will is present with me.
But how to perform what is good I do not
find. For the good that I will to do, I
do not do. But the evil that I will not
to do that I practice. Now if I do what
I will not do, not to do, it is no
longer I who do it, but sin that dwells
in me. So what you said, you know, it it
it he's alluding to the fact that it's
the will. And Ellen White talks a lot
about the will. The the the practice of
the will. Now, here's the last thing I
want to say.
I have a series of sermons that that the
burden is if you're using your will not
to do something, it's the incorrect use
of the will.
My mindset says you need to put Jesus at
the point of attack. Here's what I mean.
If I have a problem with women, if I
think about not doing anything with
women, I am still thinking about Yeah.
women. So, what I've got to do is
replace that thought with with Jesus.
So,
>> I don't use my will not to do. I use my
will to focus on Christ.
>> And then Christ makes the replacement in
my life. And then as I keep doing that,
>> um,
>> I actually do begin to change because
he's talking about the justification.
Well, yeah. The moment you say, "I'm
sorry," God takes care of that. But you
need to move on to the sanctification.
You got to get the victory over those
sins. And the only way you can do that
is put Christ at the point of attack and
not to use the will negatively but to
use it positively.
>> Amen.
>> You know, I appreciate the last thing
you said. Everything is of course, but
that I think that is the key because uh
many times we're just trying to shield
ourselves against sin and always in the
preventative mode
without the connection with Christ.
>> So that's the key. The will is given
only so that I can connect with Christ
and he does the rest.
>> Yes.
>> Because you cannot do the rest. You
cannot do it on on your own.
>> Very good.
>> Amen. Amen. Restore. And to me, the word
restore is the Lord restores.
>> Yes.
>> He restores the joy of salvation. It is
like you said, you have said you submit
your will and he does the work. Amen.
>> It's not going to be your own work, but
God will doing the work in you.
>> In 1 Corinthians 9, Paul says, I keep my
body un under. He's he's he's he's
telling you there's going to be a fight.
Yes.
>> This is not going to be easy. It's not
eating oatmeal in the morning. You're
going to have to fight this thing all
day long.
>> So,
>> if you've been involved in a habit for a
long time,
>> God may be pleased to totally remove it,
remove it from you in a snap,
>> or he may make you fight your way out
like you walked your way in.
>> Yes.
>> So, the fact that you're struggling is a
good thing. When you give up struggling,
well, then you've gone one step too far.
So you're struggling, keep on
struggling. Realize you do not struggle
alone and Christ is struggling with you.
Amen. And thank you for that question.
>> Um, we want to just touch on this last
thing, a second part of this question.
Uh, a family member keeps me mismanaging
money and refuses advice. Am I being
uncristlike by no longer helping them
pay their bills? I worry I'm enabling
their irresponsibility. Hm. Well, I
think that it's very important that we
approach this situation with a lot of
caution and a lot of a lot of wisdom.
What I mean by that is I I know that
some individuals may say, "Yeah, just
cut him off completely. You know, he's
mismanaged money, you wasting money
away, and all those things." Um I think
that you need if you have a if you're a
member of a a brother or sibling to this
individual or a parent to that someone
like that you do have a duty to provide
the needs I'm talking about a place to
sleep place to eat you know enough to
eat whatnot in the sense that that
individual should not be a a a burden to
someone else or to uh the church for
example I've seen some sadly in some
advent into circles people cutting off
uh family members and then the church
has to come up and pay for these
individuals needs. So I think that if
you have the remains and you are to give
him a a room to board or whatn not
that's one thing now to give money to
enable them on a vise or to en or give
them money or uh providing them for
their expending on things that are not
conducive to Christ that I think is a
mistake
>> because we are responsible for all the
money that the Lord has given us.
>> Yes.
>> And like the prodical son you know uh he
took his portion and he wasted away. Now
the father didn't keep sending him money
when he was away in the world and you
know faring away. Now when he came to
return when he had nothing and came
willing to submit to the father he
received him and that's the key we can
receive them in our home and sustain
them and give them what they need.
Unless that person is surrendered to
Christ and willing to be led by the the
spirit of God, giving money enabling
people to continue living a life of
gambling or whatever it is is an
absolute sin in the God's eyes. Right?
So yeah, it it seems that the case here
is is just what you describe. It looks
like the person, this individual here is
trying to do his or her best to help
this family member
because uh it says that they're refusing
advice. It looks like he or she are
trying to help them financially, trying
to help them plan financially better,
give them good advice, but they keep
refusing that advice. And he feels that
now him paying their bills is enabling
them. And I think I think that's true in
this situation because unfortunately
some people will not use their money
wisely.
>> Yes.
>> They just recklessly spend money. They
refuse to accept advice and I think in
those situations we are not expected
>> to to help
um because then we will be condoning
this in responsibility. Now, worst case
scenario, let's say there are children
involved and and then and these people
go homeless, then there's there needs to
be something done about even if there
was their mistake, we need to do
something for them. But but I think even
though it's hard and it is a difficult
decision to do because we love our
family members. Um but you know I I have
a I have a nephew that uh thank God he's
doing better today
>> but um some years ago he he was
struggling with drugs and he would he
knew how to talk to my mom to to give
him money. uh he would say no and he
would always put the girls his girls no
you know we don't have anything to eat
things like that but we would give him
money and and he would just go and and
use it for drugs then we stopped giving
him money and we were just buying
clothes for them and the girls he would
even sell their clothes for for drugs
>> so it came to a point that we said you
know we cannot help um he was homeless
for some time we we we helped the girls
but through them um thank god he he
overcame that he's doing better Amen.
>> But I told my mom, you know, we need to
we need to stop giving him for some
time. He needs to know what it's like to
be in the streets so that he knows and
understands that he is taking the wrong
course in his life. Fortunately, he he
learned the lesson, but sometimes
it tough, but that's what you got to do.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, again, I want to pull together your
your thoughts because they're both very
very good. When I was pastoring in New
York, we had a large church and we had a
consistent stream of people coming to
us, I need food, I need to eat, this
kind of thing. And so we sat down and we
said, you know, money is not the answer
to everything.
>> Exactly.
>> Some people who ask for money,
>> the last thing they need is cash.
>> Yeah.
>> So if a person came and said, I'm
hungry, we developed a voucher system
with the local supermarket. We would
give them a voucher. they could go down
there and get what they want. I found
many times they didn't want the voucher.
They wanted the money. Well, we're not
giving you money. We'll give you a
voucher. If you're if hunger is your
problem, we'll take care of your hunger
problem,
>> but we're not going to just give you
cash because cash is not the answer.
Cash is your problem because you're not
spending it well. So, you know, James
says, if if you lack wisdom,
>> ask.
>> Amen. And God will give you the kind of
wisdom you need to handle some of these
problems because it does take solommonic
wisdom sometimes to get through some of
these things. And then people who are on
drugs are very crafty, very sneaky, very
slick in their presentations and they'll
find a soft touch and they'll milk that
thing and milk it and milk it and milk
it and you think I'm I'm helping them.
Well, maybe you're not. Maybe you're
hurting them.
>> Yeah.
>> Good point.
>> All right, let's go on. I think uh for
some reason I think this next question
from um Zimbabwe was answered in a
previous program. So I want to jump over
to 81 and we've only got a few minutes.
Okay,
>> so we want to ch look at uh 5081.
How should a Christian respond when a
child has autism
uh with autism refuses certain foods to
the point of extreme resistance or fear
even though they've accepted the same
foods unknowingly before? How can we
approach this with wisdom, love, and
guidance from the Bible or Ellen White's
writings?
>> All right, pastor. I think that, you
know, it's a it's a kind of a sensitive
question and a little bit of a difficult
question to truly give an answer to, but
I I will say that the principle in James
15 is perhaps the best biblical answer
we can give to this.
>> It says there, "If any of you lack
wisdom,
let him ask of God who gives to all
liberally and without reproach, and it
will be given to him."
And I can read verse six. But let him
ask you in faith with no doubting for he
who doubts is like a wave of the sea
driven and tossed by the wind. So the
first thing I would say as as a parent,
this individual or mom or dad that has
this child, they need to ask the Lord
for wisdom and ask truly the Lord. Say,
"Lord, help me to give give me wisdom to
to approach with love, with sympathy in
a way that I can connect with my child
and provide him or her then the the
things that they need." Besides that
asking of the Lord, I think that that
individual needs to uh ask a
professional, a medical professional who
could perhaps give them ideas and
concepts of how to approach what type of
foods this individual needs and whatnot.
Yes. So that it's not necessarily uh you
know a fight of in her own or or his own
but at the same time you are uh advised
by individuals who have a better
understanding of the medical aspect of
what this child will need.
>> Amen. Well well well said. Um
the thing about autism it there's a
spectrum. There's very autistic children
then there's mildly autistic children.
This is really beyond our ability. And
one of the things I think we as pastors
>> ought to recognize, we don't know
everything.
>> Exactly.
>> We can't answer every question.
>> There are professionals who are
>> assigned and designed to help this kind
of situation.
>> I like what you said, uh, Pastor David.
Um, if you lack wisdom,
>> the Lord is willing to give you wisdom.
Yes. And your wisdom may be don't just
ask the pastor. Ask the doctor.
>> Exactly.
answer the doctor because he's trained
to do that and he wants to do that. So
we we we took the question not because
we had an answer but because we wanted
to have respect to the time you took to
ask the question and and let you know
that we read all questions and try as
best we can to answer all questions. But
the truth be told, we don't have the
answer for every question. And when you
don't know, the best thing to do is say
you don't know.
>> Yeah.
>> Amen. All right. M
>> um the next question I don't know if we
really have time to get into this. Mine
says it's it's dealing with the 24
elders.
>> Mhm.
>> Um I've got a a long list of notes here
and it's not the kind of thing that we
can take in 2 minutes and 35 seconds
that we have. So we're going to go over
that and that's
>> we'll get back to it another episode.
Absolutely.
>> You can you can in the meantime you can
find Pastor Bore series on the 24
elders. He discusses that topic at
length.
>> Yes, indeed he does. That's what the
thing I put right at the top. And I
think uh Elder Elder Boore has great
great um information on uh this
question. Now we're going to do this one
very very quickly. Um
let's take the second part because we're
going to answer that faster. Second
question are chapters 36 to 40 of the
great controversy in chrono
chronological order. I know we've proven
that Matthew 24 is in chronological
order, but what about those chapters?
>> Pastor, I think that uh I'm glad that
this individual asked this question
about the great controversy. I I think
that the Lord has given us a panorama, a
a window to the future in the great
controversy of especially the closing
scenes. And as you study that chapter or
those chapters along with spir with the
Bible with Matthew 24, you will realize
that there is a chronological
understanding and they're pretty much go
in a chronological order. So I I think
that the answer the short answer is yes,
they're in chronological order. But I
believe that as you pray to the Lord and
you reach with the scriptures, you'll
see the the you know that they're in
harmony and they're both in conical
order.
>> Yeah. It's not a strictly but it follows
a certain flow because for example in
the chapter uh liberty of conscience
threatened which is part of that
section.
>> Yes,
>> the first half of that chapter she goes
back into history again some details
>> but that is to emphasize the current
discussion that she is having. But
anyways we we ran out of time.
>> Our time has slipped away from us. Thank
you for writing. Thank you for watching.
God bless you. We'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye.
[Music]